زرت عده مناطق تحديدا في شرق اوكرانيا
اليوم من البؤره الاكثر شعارا هي بخموته
نتوقف معك رائده عند حركه بؤر المعارك في
الشرق الاوكراني منذ بدايه هذا العام
نعم حسنيه لو لو قسمنا الجبهه خط الجبهه
هو 1300 كيلو متر ولكن لو قسمنا في شمال
من كريمينا من الشمال وحتى هو خط
استعاده استعاده الجيش الاوكراني في شهر
سبتمبر ولكن
جنوبنا الخال الجزء الثاني وهو الاهم حيث
تدور المعارك في مدينه بخموت حيث يقاتل
الجيش الروسي بشكل دفاعي منذ الصيف الماضي
ويقاء بشكل هجومي ويقاتل الجيش الاوكراني
بشكل دفاعي ما تم الاعلان عنه منذ سقوط
مدينه سوليدار هو هي مناطق موجوده في شمال
محيط مدينه مخموت بعيده عن المدينه يعني
15 كيلو متر هي عباره عن مجموعه
قوى يقاتل تقاتل فيها ميليشيا او مجموعه
فاجنا ومنذ سقوط سوليدان من يعلن عن
التقدم على الارض هو وخصوصا في المنطقه
الشماليه هي مجموعه فاجنال من
نقاتل دفاعا عن بلدنا لانه من المناطق
التي يجب ان تبقى في ايدينا ولن نترك اي
تقدم للجيش الروسي فيها كل التقدم للجيشه
الروسي من الصيف الماضي هي مناطق بسيطه
جدا في محيط في مدينه بخموت مكلفه جدا
بمقارنه بالتقدم الذي قام به مكلفه من حيث
عدد الجنود ومن حيث عدد الاليات شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذه الاضاءه من كرامات في
شرق اوكرانيا الزميل رائد ابو زيد